vamos a tomar 63 y lo dividiremos entre
y esto está bastante tranquilo ya que el
63 es más grande que el 35 por lo que
cuántas veces cabrá el 35 en 63 es 35
por 2 es igual a 70 y es mucho
simplemente será 1
lo pondré con este color 11 x 35 es
igual a 35 y 163 le restamos 35
tendremos 8
este se convierte en 428
y podemos decir sabes 63
entre 35
es igual a
1 un entero con un residuo
de 20 a 8
sin embargo sabemos que esta no es la
respuesta que estamos buscando realmente
no es la mejor respuesta que podemos dar
lo que podemos hacer entonces es llegar
a una división tal que nos dé mucha más
precisión y por ello sabemos que
tendremos 1 punto algo
para que nosotros podamos saber hasta
qué decimal nos acercaremos en esta
división lo que haremos es colocar
precisión en nuestro número
original y tendremos 63 puntos y
añadiremos estos ceros que simplemente
nos dan precisión sin afectar el número
63 es igual que 63.000 pero nosotros si
nos ayuda para poder hacer nuestra
división cambió el color entonces al
colocar este punto decimal nos
aseguramos que esté exactamente a la
misma altura arriba y bajamos el primer
cero
y ahora si tenemos 280 lo podremos
dividir entre 35 cuántas veces nos cabe
35 dentro de 280 pensemos si hace un
momento decíamos que 2 por 35 son 70 por
4 son 140 por 8
me parece que serán 280 vamos a hacer la
multiplicación de este lado 35 x
8 x 5 es igual a 40 llevamos 48 por 3 24
420 8 perfecto nos queda perfecto
entonces colocaremos 280 entre 35 es
igual a 8
y tenemos ya este número 8 por 35 es
igual a 280 y si a 280 le restó 280
tendremos un 0 con lo que indicamos que
hemos terminado nuestra división ya
tenemos de residuos 0
ahora podemos decir entonces con esa
actitud que el resultado de 63
entre 35 será igual a 1.8
y este será nuestro resultado final